[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half an hour
we'll see what's making headlines with
the journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the political commentator
Bennett expense so let's see what's on
at some of those front pages and we'll
start with the front of the telegraph
which leads with a warning from the
French Energy company evf that it may
have to shut down two of the older UK
nuclear plants it runs next year as a
result the windfall tax on its profits
which The Firm says may the cost of
keeping those plants going prohibitive
fuel bills make the front of the mail on
Sunday this is the Scottish Edition
which says UK households are paying
billions extra in a stealth tax to fund
the bailout of collapsed energy firms
the Sunday Express carries an exclusive
interview with the Prime Minister
promising better times ahead with what
he calls a new year master plan to
kick-start the economy
the Sunday Times leads with new research
suggesting wavering voters could still
switch to the Tories at the next
election
the Sunday people reports that pressure
on the NHS means patients are dying
before they ever get a hospital bed
the mirror says that former royalade
lady Hussey who resigned after asking a
uk-born charity boss where she was
really from is to get an invitation to
King Charles's coronation lady has he
has apologized for that incident while
the star continues its campaign to help
the country's pubs recover from the
economic crisis by asking people to
forsake dry January and sign up to what
it's calling the 1st of January
and a reminder that by scanning that QR
code to see on your screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of the papers while you watch
along with us
uh we're joined tonight by the
journalist and author Christina
Patterson and by the political
commentator Benedict Spence Christina
Benedict's Happy New Year's Eve to you
both and let's get straight into this
and go to the front page of the Sunday
Times uh Bennett let's start with you on
this and this is the times uh saying
there's some new in-depth reporting
saying that that labor leading the polls
may not be quite as firm as uh some
would like it to be
yes and this is uh you know I suppose
trying to give as it says giving Tori's
fresh hope as they go into a New Year
and hope to banish the ghosts of 2022 uh
firmly behind them and it has been a
particularly um uh riotous year I
suppose if you are the conservative
party
um and you know given that we've all
been talking for a very long time about
uh how it's likely that the Tories are
likely to lose the next general election
and it's question of like how many
rather than if uh perhaps this will come
uh as welcome news to the conservatives
and it's based on the idea that there
are an awful lot of floating voters and
undecided voters uh around the country
uh at the moment and it cites the red
wall
um as part of that and yeah the idea
that these things can still be clawed
back it also cites uh the idea of the
shy Tori which is something that I don't
think is necessarily as as big a factor
as some would like it to be but
nonetheless it tries to paint the idea
that all is not lost uh for Rishi sunak
now I do happen to agree with that
slightly that all is not lost and I
would simply point to the the seismic
lead the Boris Johnson had overcast
armor this time two years ago and how
quickly that uh you know turned on its
head so that you know strange things can
happen in politics but I do think that
there is a lot of this is quite wishful
thinking I think as everybody who pays
any attention to politics knows uh you
lose elections because your core base
and your undecided don't turn out for
you and just because people are
undecided right now uh in large numbers
that doesn't mean that they are
necessarily gonna go to the voting
booths and hold their notes and vote
conservative in two years time I still
think it's a you know it's a it's it's a
it's a mammoth battle that and I think
it's very interesting that the end of
this story uh then lists a number of
things that Russia sunak is planning to
do in the New Year in order to fix the
mess that the the the the the the
previous conservative governments uh
have left us with and I think actually
that spells it all there are a lot of
people who are undecided but that
doesn't mean that the government has a
particularly good rap sheet to provide
for these people come the next election
yeah that list is quite long and
extensive and and because you know I
wonder what you make of the reporting
here I mean there's a there's a line in
it that says uh Lord man of some Peter
mandelson warning kissed armor not to
stray away from Center ground policies
well I think European mandelson's
absolutely right about that and I think
um this uh polling is um kind of
salutary reminder to uh kind of liberal
remainers like me that uh that Kirsten
is probably right to stick to the center
ground that he has been sticking to to
the point where he is saying not only
are we not going to is he not going to
make any attempts to reverse brexit
which he has said he wouldn't do anyway
but also that uh he's not looking at
renegotiating the relationship with the
EU
um which is very very unpopular with
many labor voters but he understands and
this poll
um reminds us that he cannot win power
without winning over the red wall these
are the seats that he has to win and
these people were traditionally labor
voters but you know the old all ideas of
what was traditional and what isn't have
disappeared in recent years and they are
very very socially conservative I do
think one area where Libra are going to
have trouble in worrying these voters is
the whole trans issue actually because
there are still certain areas where
labor is um very much not in tune with
the electorate but broadly speaking I
think what will blow all this polling
apart is that next year sadly and I
don't want to be saying this on New
Year's Eve of all days but I think it is
going to be a very tough year for people
economically I think mortgages are going
to be very high renegotiate people
renegotiating mortgages are going to be
facing costs of an issue of perhaps up
to 3 000 pounds a year energy bills are
going to remain high the cost of living
is going to remain high and failing a
miracle the war in Ukraine is going to
continue and pressure on energy is going
to continue so I think actually
ultimately the economy stupid is going
to be what's ways things and I think
that's what will mean that case keeps
the case timer will probably win power
but I think he has a lot more work to do
in convincing the electorate of why they
should should vote for him other than
that he's not a Tory yeah and no need to
apologize for for the Gloom we're
perhaps facing next year Christina is
hard to avoid isn't it and speaking of
which let's stay with you and look at
the front page of the Sunday people now
and this is a reporting of the the state
of the NHS and an emergency care you may
have seen our report earlier about
ambulances queuing outside a hospital in
Stoke on Trent and this reporting says
as the headline there tells us patients
died before they're even getting a bed
yes
um yeah well I'm sorry I'm gonna have to
add more Gloom here because
um yeah the NHS is in a terrible State
and we're hearing awful reports of
people waiting there was that there's a
story of one person had to wait 99 hours
to get a bed there are people waiting on
the floors and corridors
um in a e and unfortunately for example
they're running out of portable oxygen
in lots of hospitals they're a critical
incidents in lots of hospitals very high
rates of covid very high rates of flu
and just an NHS that is creaking at the
scenes and I think and nobody's
currently striking so this is without
strikes I think this is going to be you
know another another kind of Swing
factor for voters because at the moment
I think anyone who goes near the NHS can
see it's really not coping and um it's
that is you know without the fact that
staff are underpaid and in my view
rightly needing pay Rises but it's just
it there's there are not enough staff
there's nothing enough money the whole
thing is just not properly resourced and
I think if the Tories don't solve that
which I'm afraid they're unlikely to
then that's another reason I think they
probably won't win the next election and
Benedict bringing you in though I guess
this speaks to that first story doesn't
it the challenge facing where she's
doing if he's to win people over and we
haven't got the front page here but the
express he he writes uh an article there
to talking about you know good times to
come and I do wonder if the NHS is is
part of his plan to try and turn things
around
yes I did think that was a bit audacious
of her issue soon acts are basically
right not bad on the front page of the
express going things can only get better
um but it's it really it I think it's it
adds to the sort of the sense of malaise
that I think Christina and I are
probably going to be projecting through
the screen uh on New Year's Eve and
that's because I think that there is a
real timidity around both political
parties actually in this country but we
have to sort of you know start with
conservatives because they are the ones
that have been in power for 12 years
really I think the British public are
not stupid they're not children there
has been this idea this myth I think has
carried on for a long time that you
cannot touch the NHS the NHS is the
sacred cow it's the state religion and
nothing can be done to criticize it
nothing can be done to change it but we
see year after year after year and it
was the same actually under labor to a
lesser degree but has certainly been
exacerbated under the Tories it is
creaking it is not fit for purpose I
think a government a prime minister
needs to come along and say look this
the way that we fund it the way that it
is set up the amount of money that we
pay for it how many you know places we
make available for people to become
doctors and nurses at universities
almost every Echelon of this institution
which is the third most staffed
institution on the planet after Walmart
and the Chinese military none of this is
working as it should be and actually we
have to be honest with ourselves and say
we have an aging population we are all
becoming poorer we're going to have to
think of different ways to fund this in
order to make sure that it does get the
money but also to make sure that it is
more efficient now I don't think that
that's the U.S system nobody thinks that
that's the U.S system because of course
that's always the thing that everybody
says all right it's going to be
privatized like they have in America it
is perhaps the one thing actually I
think that we have failed to do both uh
I suppose if you you know if you want to
take it down that line you know
brexiteers remain as if there was one
thing that you were going to take from
Europe that has been sort of magnificent
above all else it is that in Europe they
have lots of fantastic Health Care
Systems and the UK steadfastly continues
to fail to learn from this there are
there are other options and we need a
bold government to make this
generational change yeah bold new
thinking I think for their benefits
right let's just keep moving we haven't
got much time but I want to get to the
front page of the telegraph now and it's
not specifically about the strikes in
the NHS Benedict but it's about strikes
more broadly and tell us about this
reporting here because uh we've had talk
from issues you know that he's going to
crack down on striking workers but this
reporting suggests that it could be a
good few months away
yes and I think that that is sensible
actually because I don't think that you
want to be presenting yourself as
unnecessarily hostile to striking
workers especially as we've touched on
people working in the NHS who everybody
agrees have been underpaid for a very
long time
um but I do also think that there's an
element of cynicism to this which is
that the longer you sort of draw it out
you can perhaps Bank on the idea given
that everybody almost everybody in
society is becoming poorer and is
struggling both private and public
sector you can sort of rely or hope that
members of the private sector and the
general public at large will begin to
lose Sympathy for the strikers that has
certainly happened with the rail
Strikers they had a lot more support
than they currently do I'm not sure if
it'll be the case for nurses I think
nurses would always retain in an element
of sympathy but it might happen for say
teachers um or other areas of the public
sector that may go on strike and then at
that point Rishi sunak will come in with
these slightly more measured response of
making sure that there are minimum
Staffing levels whether or not that
that's fair I'm not sure but it's
certainly a fun a more sensible idea
than I think the original Liz truss plan
which was just to make it a lot more
difficult for some Industries to strike
at all which as with everything under
Liz trust was just generally a bit of a
car crash so at least you know there is
a central semblance of sense there in
Rishi sunach but nonetheless nobody
likes the idea of the erosion of the
right to strike because it is a
fundamental principle of you being able
to withdraw your labor to improve your
terms and if working conditions are
dangerous and underpaid as they are in
some sectors in this country you should
be allowed to do that and a government
shouldn't be putting you in a position
where you feel you have to strike okay
uh and Christina just a quick thought
from you then on that I mean the six
months also is I guess the time when
some of these striking workers will be
balloted again about continuing their
strike action
yes I mean I I think the reason for the
delay is actually more because there are
likely to be objections to it than that
Richie sunak wants to delay at six
months I think the House of Lords that
the piece says that the House of Lords
is quite likely to
um to object in all kinds of ways and I
don't blame them but I think the real
issue here is that the government is
absolutely refusing to negotiate with
the Striking workers by pretending that
it can't give 19 pay Rises for example
to nurses now I I think 19 pay rise was
a tactical error from the nurses they
should not have answered something so
high but everyone knows that strikes are
about negotiation and the fact that the
government is refusing to negotiate is
is is disastrous and I think the big
question will be who can win in terms of
who can who will be blamed for these
strikes will it be the Striking workers
for example the nurses or will it be the
government at the moment I think the
government is being blamed more than the
strikers and the question is will that
shift over the next few months and I
hope that the nurses win this one I have
less sympathy for some of the other the
workers but I think nurses have been
consistently underpaid and I think the
government playing Hardball in this way
it's both it's losing the pr battle as
well as what in my view is right okay
Christina Benedict appreciate that uh
run out of time in this section but
we'll have more from you later thanks
for being with us now nuclear power
plants could face shutdowns over the tax
on their windfall profits that is the
story that's making the front page of
the Sunday Telegraph and we'll discuss
that and much more at its break
foreign
[Music]
with us the journalists and author
Christina Patterson and the political
commentator Benedict Spence for a look
at the front pages as they arrive right
let's go through them Benedict Christina
thanks for staying with us let's get
straight on because we haven't got much
time in this half but let's start with
the Sunday Telegraph now and that story
that I was just talking about before we
went to break this is EDF saying that
they could shut down some of the nuclear
plants that they run here because of the
windfall tax Christina just tell us
about the reporting in this
yeah I mean it's a reminder that
absolutely every policy has its equal
and opposite response and of course
everybody was yelling for a windfall tax
in my view rightly because it's
absolutely ridiculous that they've been
making these vast profits well we've
been you know we've been struggling so
much with ridiculously high bills and
many people are literally having to
choose between Heating and eating but
EDF who run all five nuclear power
stations in this country have said they
may have to discontinue two of them in
2024 if this windfall tax continues at
this rate and that could leave us
dangerously short of electricity
um and that's you know our kind of
safety net really is is in those two
power stations if that goes that's our
safety net gone which is very very
dangerous at a time of a global energy
crisis such as the one we have at the
moment so it is a worry for the
government and I must say I mean I I
think they were right to introduce an
energy crowd and
um well tax it was of course Labor's
idea Rachel Reeves idea which uh the
Tories eventually having objected to it
copied but it does so have very
difficult the process of governing is
that everything you do has you know it
seems to have uh you know a sort of can
have a disastrous effect so you know I
really don't envy them for having to
make these decisions she's gonna be a
tough one and Benedict what did you make
of it I mean when I first read this it
sort of reminded me of last week and
that Exxon Mobil pushing back against
the EU tax on their profits as well
we've seen sort of these big uh
providers these big companies pushing
back on that idea
I think what all of this has done and
this will actually increasingly I think
be the case amongst a lot of uh Tory
voters is push the idea that actually
the country should be looking to
nationalize parts of its energy industry
if not all of it and you know we we talk
about how the war in Ukraine has sort of
spiked Energy prices
um over the last couple of months you
need to look at who the big Winners have
been from this entire energy crisis
they've been State
um energy uh monopolies such as gazprom
in Russia or aramco in Saudi Arabia and
elsewhere if you have the Monopoly on
supply of energy and you have the
resources under your feet uh uh to your
advantages then you know the world is
your oyster it can be very useful and
you know it doesn't need to be the case
that Things become incredibly uh expense
uh incredibly expensive it's not the
case in the Gulf or North Africa it's
not the case in Russia or Scandinavia
the energy has massively surged
necessarily because they control access
to it now in this country we actually
have that we have the Holy Trinity we
still have an awful lot of fossil fuels
that we could utilize should we choose
to we have an awful lot of renewable
energy resources should we use should we
choose to we can also build nuclear
power stations in lots of areas and we
found ourselves Outsourcing everything
and turning off the Taps to certain
sources of energy it is a failure of
energy policy in this country going back
decades yeah I think people will be
surprised that they're reminded that we
don't own the nuclear plants in this
country all right let's move on to the
front of the Sunday Times and actually
uh the story of course is featured on
most of the front page this is about the
pope Christina and the passing of uh of
Pope Benedict the 16th and um a big
moment for the uh the papacy and also
now sort of calls into question what
happens next with the uh other Pope who
is uh looking kind of unwell in that
picture
uh yes well they it's not it's not an
industry it's not an area that
discriminates in favor of Youth is it
and uh so there is a kind of built-in
obsolescence to to the whole idea and of
course Pope Benedict will go down in
history being famous really for being
the only Pope for hundreds of years to
have resigned uh while still in office I
I think he I mean look he was the kind
of in many ways a gentle scholar and he
said himself that he was really kind of
more of an actual Professor figure than
a pope but he was also very very
conservative and for example in taking
the very traditional catholic line on
contraception that will have had a real
impact on women's lives in many parts of
the world so
um although I know I shouldn't speak ill
of the dead and I'm sure he was a very
good man in many many ways we also
shouldn't forget that the pronouncements
of major religious figures whether they
are Catholic or muslim-funded Mentalist
or any other religion do have a very
very real effect on the lives of of
people I mean we just have to look at
what's happening in Afghanistan at the
moment and how that's been taken over by
people who don't believe in education
um so yes it says it's a it's a sad day
but you know he was 95
. sorry to interrupt Christina we've run
a short time Benedict so I'll come back
to you another time on that thank you
both very much